mophie just absolutely killed apple's
magsafe duo with this brand new product
that has some very unique features and
offers a lot of bang for the buck
especially compared to what apple offers
and today we are gonna check it out and
also test it to see if there are any
slowdowns like apple's max a duo charger
gets both with how much power it can
give and if the phone can maintain that
peak power to see if this is the
ultimate charging solution so let's go
ahead and take a look i really love how
they designed this and of course the
most important part is that you have mac
save and 15 watt fast charging compared
to apples which isn't that fast and
slows down even more now one thing
that's very interesting about this is
the fact that on the box it lists the
iphone 12 pro max doesn't even mention
iphone 13 now i think that is because
apple has been holding back third-party
companies from making chargers that
actually charge at full 15 watt mag safe
speeds so you'd have to buy alternatives
that are lower quality and a lot slower
so let's take a look at this right here
it's a very very unique design we have
this little pouch with this kind of felt
like material so it's very soft it has
this little elastic strap with a button
to go ahead and pack everything up nice
and tidy so it's cool that it's all in
one solution like this and it just feels
really nice taking a look inside we see
that there is a lot of room in here this
pouch is of course a lot bigger than
apple's kind of mac safe duo and in here
we actually get a power brick that is
included in the box thankfully after so
many products have stopped shipping and
mophie is still giving us one and it's
important because you're going to need
to have one that is powerful enough of
course we also have
a usb c to usb c cable so no lightning
here like apples has and this power
brick is a 30 watt power adapter that
way there's enough power to give you all
three products where apple with theirs
max save duo they don't give you a power
adapter and they recommend getting a 20
watt one but if you do that you'll
actually only run up to 14 watts instead
of 15 for your phone and then if you
start charging your watch as well then
that power drops and you get even slower
charging so it's nice that it is in the
box and it is proper but we will be
testing it now do we have those two
compartments there's a little bit extra
room if you need to add something else
and let's go ahead and pull out the
actual charger itself opening this up i
have to say it has a really substantial
feel to it it has some good weight and
this material on the outside kind of
reminds me of like the google pixel
cases the really natural feeling ones uh
feels really nice has some help and then
open this up here do we have magnets
that hold stuff nope not really other
than these ones that hold it together
those are strong but here it is you have
your triple charger we have the space
with magsafe for your phone for the
apple watch and also for your air pods
now this apple watch puck let me take
the little plastic off there you can
also lift it up if you want to use it in
that like nightstand mode so you can see
the time and when it's charging or you
can drop it flat like this so overall um
quality feels really nice the rubber
feels really nice as well let's set this
down let's go ahead and plug in the
charger which is right over here on the
apple watch side and let's place our
phone down here bam we are charging i'm
going to use an app to see what the
charge speeds are going to be this app
will actually see how much wattage is
going directly to the battery and with
that we're going to use this charger to
see how much it's pulling from the power
adapter with those other devices so
that's going to be cool to see now with
that if you guys want to check this out
go ahead and check out the description
below also have some cheaper
alternatives and hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to help us reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers
but that magnus strength
it's very good
low slippage over here like they have a
nice rubbery coating
and no issues with alignment or anything
else of course we wouldn't expect that
let's place our air pods on here
these are the air pods three and let's
take off the apple watch
bam we are charging that up as well so
as you guys see it's a very simple easy
solution uh easy product and one that's
gonna be really convenient now you guys
saw that right there we don't have any
magnets here in the apple watch section
that must have been before the airpods 3
came out that would have been kind of
nice if it was another regular pad like
this of course you can't attach it here
if you're not charging your phone and
then it's going to magnetize but this
section is a bit slippery now what i'm
going to do next is take this off
and we're gonna grab a phone that's not
charged close to all the way and let's
see how much power we actually get and
if that power stays once we start adding
on our other accessories and now let's
go ahead and see how much wattage this
thing can actually give and bam there
you guys go we have 15 watts of fast
charging apple's max save duo that only
peaks at 14 watts maximum and then it
will slow down so let's go ahead and
we're going to put this back on here
let's toss on my apple watch here we're
also going to grab some air pods these
are air pods pro
because mine are fully charged we'll set
that to charge and let's test again all
right there you go our test is done
let's turn the brightness back on we
have to have the screen on while we're
charging look at that we have 14.52
watts slightly lower pretty much 15
watts and we are
uh 26
charge it's gonna start uh max safe
depending on heat can start tapering
down think a little bit later but we
have full performance and we're charging
our apple watch right now and airpods
all at the same time with that included
30 watt adapter
of course you can only do two with that
mac save duo and if you do the apple
watch and your phone it starts charging
much slower and remember that 14 and a
half watts is what's actually hitting
the battery not what is coming into the
charger so if we take a look at our
meter here i got that out it is actually
going above 21 watts being brought in to
charge all of these devices now at this
point my apple watch uh it's over 80
already as far as the charge and these
air pods the case is over 50 percent
charge too so it starts to draw a little
bit less power but you guys see there's
still nine extra watts of power to
provide uh these other devices so there
you guys go this thing looks good you
get everything that you need inside of
the box you get this nice little uh
carrying case to hold everything if
you're gonna be traveling
and you get an extra device plus full
speed charging not only if you're just
charging your iphone
but along with that even when you add
everything else you're charging
everything at once you are not limited
like you are with apple's product so you
guys let me know down below what do you
guys think of mophie's new charging
solution is this what apple should have
done in the first place release
something that gives most people uh the
ability to charge all their devices and
with no slowdowns and with that power
adapter built in to the box or included
in the box um i want to know your guys's
opinions thank you guys for watching
click that circle above to subscribe
like always we have links down below
check out one of the great videos over
there that's been max and i'll see you
in the next video
[Music]
you